vor uns liegen vier wochen verzicht und
verbot wieder eine nationale
kraftanstrengung wie die kanzlerin sagt
weil man bis zuletzt versprochen hatte
es werde keinen zweiten lok toren geben
redet man lieber vom herunterfahren oder
vom schotter richtig ist anders als im
frühjahr sollen betriebe läden und
schulen offen bleiben erlaubt ist was
sein muss verboten ist alles was spaß
macht das ziel ist das alte die kurve
drücken ist da für jedes mittel recht
und was kommt eigentlich danach darüber
wollen wir reden mit diesen gästen
tobias hans der saarländische
ministerpräsident sagt wir mussten jetzt
einschreiten
sonst wäre im dezember unser
gesundheitssystem überfordert melanie
brinkmann die virologin ist optimistisch
da jetzt so schnell gehandelt wurde kann
die dynamik unterbrochen werden
andreas gassen der chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung warnt
wir dürfen das land nicht ins koma
versetzen
gute teichert vom ärzteverband im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst ist froh
dass sich bund und länder überhaupt
geeinigt haben und robert habeck
der grünen-chef sagt uns droht eine
gesellschaftliche zerreißprobe sie sind
zu gast bei maybrit illner und die
begrüßt alle gäste sehr herzlich heute
abend live zuschauer dann sitzen wir in
zwei wochen eben wieder hier sagte die
kanzlerin beim letzten mal
und sie hatte recht behalten deutschland
im corona herbst fieberhaft steigen die
neue infektionen innerhalb einer woche
verdoppeln sich die zahlen der wert eilt
von rekord zu rekord
eine nation sieht größtenteils gut vier
wochen radikalkur verordnen bund und
länder um das virus auszubremsen
das ist eine bittere pille aber wie jede
therapie wie das medikament sind wir
überzeugt und hoffen sehr dass es auch
eine entsprechende wirkung hat deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt im monat november
beginnt vom 2
november noch einmal eine nationale
kraftanstrengung kontakt verzicht
therapieziel nummer eins wieder gastro
schließungen pause für kulturen sport
preise verbot aber schulen und kitas aus
dem vogel die länderfürsten bislang oft
mit eigenen diagnosen wollen jetzt einen
behandlungsplan es gibt keinen keinen
isolierten weg den man eigenständig
gehen kann
dennoch drohen klagen eine politische
überdosis findet die opposition
unser land soll in ein künstliches koma
versetzt werden
die schließungen die jetzt im raum
stehen sind sehr pauschal und sehr
flächendeckend sie fürchten die
nebenwirkungen
mitarbeiter der betroffenen branchen
finanzielle spritzen sorgen für
ausgleich das fieber soll wieder runter
ende november wird sich zeigen ob die
therapie anschlägt
erstaunlich einig gestern hat die
politik zwei wertvolle wochen verschenkt
mit dem durcheinander das ist zuvor gab
naja also zumindest hätte ich mir
gewünscht in der tat dass er vor 14
tagen schon etwas mehr hinbekommen
hätten als uns auf dem kleinsten
gemeinsamen nenner zu einigen
dann glaube ich werden wir etwas früher
dran als wir jetzt sind aber wenn man
rings um uns herum schaut merkt man wir
sind immer noch recht früh dran
mit diesen harten maßnahmen ich hätte
mir sie weiter gewünscht ganz ohne frage
aber zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gläubig sind
sie richtig und ich habe auch immer
gefordert dass braucht bundesweit
einheitliche maßnahmen deswegen ist das
schon ganz wichtiger schritt teil
shutdown herunterfahren gegen s der
gestern tatsächlich noch darum einen
lock down zu vermeiden oder ging es nur
darum das wort zu vermeiden also wichtig
war uns und das ist wichtig gewesen im
früheren es bleibt richtig die
wirtschaft nicht ohne grund zu
beschädigen und die wichtigen
handelsströme aufrecht zu erhalten das
war das was uns geleitet hat das ist
auch mit ein grund weshalb wir gesagt
haben kitas und schulen bleiben offen
aber das haben wir auch getan um die
familien nicht nochmal in die schärfsten
belastung reinzubringen wie das im
früher war ich glaube dass es wichtig
ist ist unterscheidet uns von lok downs
in anderen ländern wo wirklich alles zum
erliegen gekommen ist und die menschen
obendrein auch noch gehindert waren sich
ein kilometer aus der wohnung zu bewegen
wie das in frankreich war so etwas
wollten wir sicherlich vermeiden
aber fakt ist das ist schon ein locker
und den wir jetzt haben und es haben
sehr viele menschen auch genau so kommen
sehen und werden darunter zu leiden
haben robert habeck ist bei uns von den
grünen differenzierte maßnahmen
regionale maßnahmen so wünschte man sich
das noch vor zwei wochen jetzt wo die
hütte brennt ruft alles nach dem bund
einigkeit gibt offensichtlich nur in der
größten not
wie schädlich war das durcheinander der
tag gestern war auch das eingeständnis
dass die differenzierten maßnahmen nicht
funktioniert haben und wenn man den
sommer zurück denkt und sich daran
erinnert dass die ersten tests für alle
urlaubsrückkehrer gemacht wurden als wie
urlaubs rückkehr aus dem urlaub
zurückkamen dass die ersten diskussionen
über schulgipfel waren als die schulen
geöffnet haben dass wir die erste
bundeseinheitliche verabredung der
ministerpräsidenten zu obergrenzen für
veranstaltungen ende september er liebt
haben dann wird man feststellen dass wir
viele fehler gemacht haben dass viel
zeit verschenkt wurde
hat nicht auch die opposition haben
nicht auch sie ferien vom virus gemacht
also wenn man genau hinschaut sieht man
dass wir immer wieder angemahnt haben
obergrenzen einzuführen differenziert
vorzugehen wir haben immer vorschläge
gemacht wie man mehr personal an die
schulen holt kleinere klassen macht und
so weiter die app war immer thema das
die teuer war aber nicht das leistet was
man sich vorgestellt hat aber in der tat
haben auch wir nicht gesagt wenn das
nicht passiert dann haben wir in der
oktober ein lock down also insofern
diese diese wohin das führt das habe ich
mir auch nicht wollen können in der tat
dass man gesehen hat dass bestimmte
dinge unzureichend sind das haben wir
bemängelt aber es wäre auch ein bisschen
naseweis ich es hier hinzusetzen und zu
sagen wir hätten alles besser gewusst
oder so ist es nicht man kann
rückblickend erkennen
wir haben ja auch eine garantie bekannt
dass viele sachen nicht gut gemacht
wurden
so und jetzt kommt die konsequenz ist
das eingeständnis der hilflosigkeit mit
den bordmitteln die wir uns angeeignet
haben kommen wir in dem moment nicht
weiter und deswegen tragen wir das jetzt
auch in der not mit
die grünen fragen mit ja schon sehen
dass die situation sich auch geändert
hat im vergleich zum früher oder auch
zum sommer deutschland war ja sehr
unterschiedlich betroffen von der kurve
19 pandemie jetzt haben wir in ganz
deutschland in allen bundesländern
gleichförmiges ansteigender kurve und
deswegen warten gegensatz zum früher wo
zum beispiel bayern saarland sehr stark
betroffen waren andere nicht so sehr ist
jetzt auch notwendig bundesweit
einheitliche maßen
zu treffen und ich finde auch nicht dass
wir über den sommer nichts getan haben
ich meine das ganze lockern aufgrund von
zurückgehenden zahlen
das war ja sehr viel schwieriger
eigentlich als im grunde verordnung zu
schreiben über einen weitgehenden
lockdown den wir zu beginn hatten und da
muss ich dann schon mal für alle
bundesländer sagen auch für baden
württemberg das ja grün regiert ist da
haben die regierungen sich wirklich sehr
viel mühe gegeben das gut zu machen da
sind gelder im haushalt eingestellt
worden und wirtschaftliche folgen
abzumildern
da es sich vorbereitet worden in den
schulen um nach den sommerferien zu
starten ich würde es nicht so pauschal
sagen dass gar nichts gemacht aber das
ist im herbst winter noch mal richtig
schlimm werden könnte und eine zweite
welle drohen könnte das haben nicht nur
die virologen gesagt eine von ihnen
begrüßen wie melanie brinkmann ist bei
uns professorin an der tu braunschweig
verbringt man jetzt fahren wir also vier
wochen lang das land rund ist die
pandemie danach im griff also manchmal
sehr schwierige frage die ich ihnen
nicht eindeutig beantworten kann frau
ich glaube es ist jetzt ganz wichtig wie
gut wir durch diese nächsten vier wochen
kommen denn nur weil jetzt ja verbote
ausgesprochen werden dass wir die unsere
partys zu hause reduzieren auf maximal
zehn personen mit zwei haushalten heißt
es nicht dass sich jeder daran hält und
das ist jetzt glaube ich nicht nur
glaube ich es ist total entscheidend
dass wir das jetzt in den vier wochen
gut hinbekommen dass wir wieder auf
zahlen kommen
die kontrollierbar werden und dann sehe
ich da sehr optimistisch auf die auf die
nächsten wochen
es muss sich aber auch einiges ändern
also wir müssen die zahlen ja nicht nur
jetzt reduzieren so dass die
gesundheitsämter den kontakt nach
volkenroda also das containment was ja
eigentlich die beste strategie mit einer
pandemie umzugehen dass sie das wieder
in den griff bekommen wir müssen die
gesundheitsämter auch dabei unterstützen
und da muss jetzt noch einiges passieren
das kann frau teichert ihnen glaube ich
sehr gut
genau darstellen wie sie sich das
vorstellen könnte begrüßen wir gleich
zunächst ist andreas gassen vorzustellen
der chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung
vergessen sie sehen diesen shutdown
kritisch dazu kommen wir noch aber auch
sie sagen wir dürfen diese kurve nicht
ins uferlose steigen lassen wie kriegen
wir die nach ihrer meinung runter also
ich glaube im ziel gibt es wohl keinen
dissenz natürlich kann man nicht
tatenlos zuschauen wie nicht
infektionszahlen sondern im nachgang der
infektions natürlich auch die
erkrankungszahlen und die schwerkranken
in die ins endlose streit selbst unser
gesundheitssystem ist natürlich nur
begrenzt belastbar insofern ist völlig
klar da müssen wir ran es gibt halt nur
nicht nur einen weg der nach rom führt
und wir hätten uns einen anderen weg
vorgestellt jetzt ist der lockdown der
ja auch kein richtiger lockdown ist
weshalb man sicherlich auch zweifel kann
aber dann auch so durch griffig ist wie
man sich das wünscht jetzt ist er hat
beschlossen jetzt hoffen wir alle
inständig dass es greift und werden alle
froh wenn die zahlen wirklich im
dezember so sind dass man sich nicht
entspannt zurücklehnen kann aber dass
man zumindest ein gefühl hat dass die
pandemie kontrollierbar ist das sehe ich
noch nicht so wirklich weil wir im
dezember nicht in der situation sein
werden dass wir neben stoff haben wir
werden auch im januar noch kein
impfstoff haben und wenn wir den einen
bekommen wäre mir den so geringen mengen
haben dass wir wenn wir glück haben
risikogruppen oder besonders exponierte
berufsgruppen impfen können das heißt
wir brauchen für diesen marathon den uns
diese pandemie auferlegt der ist ja
nicht freiwillig gewählt brauchen wir
eine nachhaltige strategie und insofern
wir haben ja ein papier dazu
veröffentlich glaube das ist ein papier
an dem trotzdem gerade jetzt auch
unbedingt weiterarbeiten sollten demnach
dem schotter und ist hoffentlich nicht
wieder vor dem stottern aber es ist
immer noch in der pandemie dazu kommen
wir gleich ich begrüße jetzt und an
dieser stelle in düsseldorf gute
teichert die chefin der ärzte und
ärztinnen des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes einen guten abend zu
ihnen frau teichert werden die
gesundheitsämter denn jetzt mit den
maßnahmen von gestern
die infektion wieder unter kontrolle
kriegen das entscheidende ist dadurch
dass jetzt die kontakte reduziert werden
sinkt natürlich auch die anzahl der
kontaktperson die man hat also wenn sich
alle daran halten und sage ich mal nur
noch im arbeitsumfeld unterwegs sind
nicht mehr im freizeit kontext
dann steigen die zahlen für die
gesundheitsämter nicht mehr so stark an
selbst wenn noch sehr viel positiv
getestete sind dann sind es eben nicht
mehr 20 bis 40 kontaktpersonen wie wir
es zuletzt beobachtet haben sondern dann
vielleicht nur noch zwei bis vier wie
wir es in der zeit im märz und im april
hatten und dann ist es natürlich viel
einfacher das abzuarbeiten als wenn sie
da immer so ganze stapel vor sich auf
dem tisch liegen haben wo sie nicht
hingucken können kaum haben sie unten
sozusagen abgearbeitet kommt oben der
stapel obendrauf
also von daher hoffe ich schon dass wenn
jetzt wirklich die kontakte reduziert
werden und wenn alle damit machen
das ist glaube ich der ganz
entscheidende punkt dass wir dann auch
in der lage sind die kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgung wieder gut abzuarbeiten
wie wir es eigentlich die ganze zeit
auch schon gemacht haben tobias hans
wellenbrecher ist das wort der stunde
alles schließen für zwei wochen oder
nicht alles schließen für vier wochen
warum hat die politik sich jetzt für
diese zweite variante entschieden
also wir hatten ja eine vorlage der
leopoldina gehabt da haben ja die
wissenschaftsorganisationen uns eben
auch vorgerechnet was wir machen müssen
um kontakte zu reduzieren quasi wie es
vorteil hat richtig gesagt hat dem virus
die hauptnahrungsquelle wegnehmen das
sind unsere kontakte und diesen
futtertrog den haben wir jetzt mal weg
gezogen in der tat haben wir nicht alle
kontakte weggezogen weil wir eben sagten
wir möchten nicht noch mal eine
situation haben wie im frühjahr wo die
familien in dieser republik wirklich auf
dem zahnfleisch gegangen sind
bin selbst vater von zwei kindern ich
weiß was es bedeutet wenn familien sich
um die betreuung kümmern müssen quasi
tag für tag und parallel dazu auch noch
arbeit nachgehen
trotzdem noch mal die frage weil die
zeit davonläuft und weil manche sagen es
ist vielleicht zu spät
während die herbstferien nicht ein guter
zeitpunkt gewesen für so einen harten
schatten auch mit den kitas und den
schulen als das jetzt zu machen über
vier wochen hätten erst mal müssen den
föderalismus dahingehend umkrempeln das
wir deutschlandweit einheitliche
herbstferien haben
und ich halte eine woche hätte ich halte
auch nichts davon dass man ferien in
irgendeiner form jetzt verlängert oder
irgendwo anders noch mal abzieht also
wenn man den eltern wirklich den
schweißen den stirn treiben möchte in
die stirn treiben möchte dann sagt man
ihnen man nimmt die hälfte der nächsten
sommerferien irgendwo weg und verlängert
sie jetzt so etwas können wir nicht
machen mit den familien es war eine
politische entscheidung wir haben
politisch gesagt wir möchten kitas und
schulen auf lassen um ihre überforderung
von familien zu vermeiden und ich glaube
auch dass wenn sich wie vorteil hat
richtig sagt sich alle daran halten und
jetzt die kontakte die wir reduziert
haben also etwa um 75 prozent
wenn das jeder macht dann können wir
auch präsenzunterricht ermöglichen und
müssen da nicht weiter rangehen
aber klar ist auch man muss es
beobachten natürlich gibt es auch in
schulen infektion da darf man den
menschen nicht irgendwo eine falsche
sicherheit vorgeben und deshalb muss man
das quasi täglich beobachten so und nun
gibt es gleich ein anderes problem was
wenn auch diesmal wieder richter und
gerichte entscheiden
diese maßnahmen sind zu pauschal und sie
sind zu flächendeckend was dann
es gehört zum rechtsstaat dazu unsere
demokratie dass gerichte ihre
entscheidungen treffen ich kann nur aus
bestem wissen und gewissen und nach
beratung mit wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern mit blick auf die
zahlen
nach gesprächen auf den
intensivstationen nach gesprächen in den
gesundheitsämtern sagen ich halte diese
maßnahmen für angemessen ich halte sie
für verhältnismäßig und ich halte sie
auch für notwendig weil wenn wir nichts
tun dann droht eben diese überforderung
des systems dann haben wir innerhalb
kürzester zeit schon anfang dezember auf
den intensivstationen eine sehr
ungünstige lage und deswegen bemühe mich
auch sehr ungern solche wortspiele wir
setzen deutschland ins künstliche koma
aus respekt vor den menschen die
tatsächlich ins künstliche koma versetzt
werden aufgrund der chor wird 19
erkrankung
ich mache mir da wirklich sorgen ich
halte diese maßnahmen für angemessen und
sie halten sie offensichtlich auch für
hinreichend begründet robert erikson
ganze problem in das ist die begründung
sie sagen dass sie eine zerreißprobe für
diese gesellschaft befürchten
denken sie dass wir hier zustände haben
können wie jüngst in neapel wo es
gewalttätig wurde auf den straßen und
gegen staatliche maßnahmen das habe ich
nicht
es gibt menschen nehmen muss man immer
alles zutrauen aber vielleicht das habe
ich nicht gemeint aber wir erleben wir
jetzt das anders als im märz die
diskussion viel kontroverser ist die
gereiztheit bei den menschen nimmt zu
wir laufen eine dunkle jahreszeit rhein
ist etwas völlig anderes wenn man sagt
ihr müsst jetzt alleine bleiben mal
ökonomische fragen anheim gestellt die
man alleine ist wirklich allein ist und
dann wenig lichter ist dann neben
depressionen und vereinsamung gefühle zu
es ist nicht ganz glücklich herr hans
kommuniziert worden was das gestern war
deswegen sagen ja reihenweise jetzt
leute wie sie schließt der restaurants
und kulturveranstaltungen wie passiert
doch gar nichts also das ist tatsächlich
ein begründung wechsel in der
bekämpfungsstrategie war dass man nicht
mehr vor gibt und sagt wir gucken
infektion sein können sondern wir
reduzieren insgesamt die kontakte und
damit das was die letzten vier fünf
monaten beigebracht wurde nicht mehr
zählt ist nicht klar genug ausgesprochen
wurden deswegen gibt es jetzt eine
eifersucht oder 1 1 die cream die werden
bevorteilt und die nicht die kirchen
bleiben offen aber die
kulturveranstaltung werden geschlossen
diskussionen und was mich besonders
beunruhigt ist dass jetzt politische
institution menschen auffordern sich
gegenseitig anzuzeigen
also wenn das bayerische kabinett
aufforderten das nachbarn ein die
nachbarn bespitzeln
dann überschreitet politik finde ich das
was ich tun sollte
sie sollte nicht menschen auffordern
einander auszuspionieren sondern
bekommen 0 durch in der vertrauen
schaffen und menschen wird so viel
zugemutet also muss das vertrauen ein
wir gefühl erzeugen und nicht einig
gefühl und alles zusammen kann einem
schon ein bisschen angst und bange
werden lassen auf welche politische
diskussionen wird zu laufen vertrauen
oder ordnungsamt darüber reden wir
gleich wir gucken vielleicht noch mal
auf das was eben der wissenschaft
geschehen ist grosso modo unterstützt
der in die medizin und unterstützen die
virologen den plan
bundesregierung und der
ministerpräsidenten aber es gibt auch
deutliche kritik und das ist neu sie
wollen zeigen wie es besser geht
zwei virologen einen mediziner an ihr
positionspapier unterstützt von
zahlreichen ärzteverbänden ein aufruf
gegen angst panik und verbote heißt es
eine kritik am erneuten runterfahren
ein kurzer sprint von vier wochen kann
vielleicht dazu führen dass sich die
situation lockert aber dann sind wir
weihnachten wieder an einem ähnlichen
punkt und müssen wir uns wieder etwas
überlegen
konkret fordern sie deshalb eine neue
strategie der kontakt verfolgung für die
gesundheitsämter ein bundesweites
ampelsystem mit neuen elementen und
einen besseren schutz für risikogruppen
zb die nachbarschaftshilfen für die
leute die sich selber isolieren wollen
oder ft2 masken für die leute die zu
hause bleiben wollen aber zum beispiel
einen besucher empfangen wollen durch
die pandemie zu kommen kein hexenwerk
sagen die mediziner abstand händewaschen
maske lüften von corona app konsequent
angewandt sei das völlig ausreichend
[Musik]
vergessen wir haben nun aber ihr alle
verfolgt dass die hhl regeln zu jüngst
nicht mehr ausreichten
das kann man so nicht sagen ob die nicht
ausreichen vielleicht reicht die die
disziplin dafür nicht aus und gerade das
leopoldina papier angesprochen und wenn
sie durch das durchlesen das werden sie
auf seite 5 im grundsatz fast analoge
ratschläge sehen in der oberliga papier
werden sie nicht finden dass da ein
doktor empfohlen wird sondern da wird
das reduzieren der kontakte ohne
vorsichtsmaßnahmen empfohlen und auf der
anderen seite steht dann im letzten
abschnitt überprüfung von hygiene
konzepten von restaurants etc pp also
explizit keine kein schließen diese
sondern ein überprüfen von konzepten das
ist auch richtig und sinnvoll die
maßnahmen der regierung denn für
übertrieben ich halte die maßnahmen ich
glaube nicht dass sie zum erfolg wenn
ich würde mir wünschen wenn wir jetzt
schon diesen diesen steinigen weg gehen
ich bin da sehr skeptisch und ich glaube
jonas widschwendter satz gesagt wir
werden in vier wochen wenn es richtig
gut läuft haben wir eine vorübergehende
reduktion der infektionszahlen aber dann
haben wir noch drei bis vier monate
winter also hoch zeit für viren vor der
brust und wir haben im prinzip ja keine
andere mittel als bisher
deshalb macht das aus unserer sicht sind
diese mittel tatsächlich auch jetzt noch
bei konsequent umzusetzen die menschen
auch damit zunehmen da bin ich völlig
bayern habe das funktioniert und ich bin
da durchaus optimistisch dass es
funktionieren kann aber es funktioniert
nur wenn wir das gemeinsam machen und
nicht solche dinge wie die in wenn die
polizei kommt dann schon wenn die
nachbarn anrufen oder wie das in essen
weiter gab wo sie einen ein formular
online ausführen konnten ob der nachbar
mit zu vielen menschen wird das ich muss
gestehen das sind dinge die findig
beklemmend und mit so was glaube ich
kriegen wir unsere mitmenschen und das
sind unsere mitmenschen das sind nicht
irgendwelche subjekte die jetzt
irgendwie am rechenschieber hergeschoben
werden und als arzt und wie das wäre
einfach noch mal betonen wiederanziehen
der runde wir sehen mensch ist mehr als
ein funktionierender biologischen
organismus und dazu gehört ganz viel und
ich habe große sorgen die teilchen bei
ihnen dass wir hier auch
kollateralschäden anrichten die weit
über die virale bedrohung hinausgehen
die unstrittig da ist und also sagen sie
wir müssen uns eine strategie überlegen
was wir eigentlich nach diesen vier
wochen machen
vielleicht bleiben wir noch mal eine
sekunde bei dem was jetzt entschieden
ist verteilten sagt ausgerechnet die
bundeskanzlerin
wir wissen von 75 prozent der
infizierten nicht wo sie sich infiziert
haben und auf der anderen seite sagt die
politik oder wenigstens tut sie so der
grund für diese zweite welle ist das
private verhalten der menschen ist das
denn belegt dass es tatsächlich unsere
privaten kontakte sind die zu diesen
hohen zahlen führen
oder passt das jetzt einfach in die
argumentation also es ist tatsächlich so
dass wir da eine eine veränderung in den
letzten wochen miterlebt haben
die kontaktperson nachverfolgung hat
sich verändert viele können oder wollen
gar nicht mehr angeben wo sie sich
vermutlich angesteckt haben das ist
sicher ein grund warum die zeit
tatsächlich so hoch ist ich habe mir das
auch noch mal bestätigen lassen von den
gesundheitsämtern also die zahl der 70
prozent ist pi mal daumen ich habe jetzt
63 von dem anderen gesundheitsamt gehört
in der größenordnung auf jeden fall
richtig
wie gesagt einmal ist es so dass die
leute nicht angeben können wo sie waren
und dann ist es natürlich so dass die
hohe zahl jetzt dadurch zustande kommt
weil nicht mehr alle fälle abgearbeitet
werden können und dadurch können
natürlich auch nicht angegeben werden wo
die leute sich angesteckt haben
und dann staut sich das natürlich auf in
dem kontext das spiel also beide
faktoren eine rolle aber ich würde sehr
gerne noch mal eingehen auf das
wasserlassen gerade gesagt hat ich bin
übrigens auch ärzten also bin auch hier
in der runde anwesend und ich habe mir
das papier sehr genau angeguckt und
würde gerne nochmal auf die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung eingehen
da steht ja drin dass die geändert
werden soll und dass die anders
aufgebaut werden soll und da an der
stelle möchte ich gerne ein haken und
noch mal sagen dass ich das tatsächlich
anders sehe ich glaube wir brauchen die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung eben
gerade um solche aussagen wie sie jetzt
hinterfragt haben frau illner treffen zu
können
wenn wir dieses gute fund was wir haben
aus der hand geben und sagen jeder
einzelne
soll das jetzt für sich machen dann
haben wir überhaupt keine erkenntnisse
keine daten mehr und wir haben keine
panini kontrolle mehr wir wissen nicht
mehr was passiert und das halte ich für
sehr gefährlich von daher stehe ich
dafür dass ich nochmal unterstützen
möchte wie dringend es ist dass wir in
dem bereich wieder in den normalen
arbeitsalltag kommen und die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung regulär
aufnehmen können das merken wir uns und
bleiben trotzdem herr hans noch mal bei
diesen privaten bereich wenn also der
private bereich jetzt das nonplusultra
ist dann muss man tatsächlich auch damit
rechnen dass die wohnung kontrolliert
wird wie herr lauterbach und
mittlerweile auch markus söder sagen
also man muss schon so ehrlich sein wenn
man auf der einen seite der gastronomie
die sich wirklich unglaublich viel mühe
gegeben hat wir keine konzepte zu
erarbeiten und so zu arbeiten das eben
möglichst wenig infektionen überhaupt
nur denkbar sind wenn man denen das
untersagt zu arbeiten da muss man schon
auf der anderen seite auch dafür sorge
tragen dass da nicht die menschen sich
komplett ins private zurückziehen und
dann eben das was sie sonst in der
gastronomie machen eben zu hause machen
deswegen sage ich die verbote für den
privaten bereich auch für den häuslichen
bereich die sind wichtig ich traue aber
durchaus den bundesbürgerinnen und
bundesbürger zu zu erkennen wenn etwas
verboten ist dass es daneben auch nun
wirklich wichtig ist sich daran zu
halten
wir werden ganz sicherlich das recht der
privatsphäre in der eigenen wohnung das
ja auch verfassungs bewährtes schützen
und achten und da auch sensibel vorgehen
aber natürlich muss man auch damit
rechnen wenn man eine große party wirft
bei sich zu hause die jetzt nicht
möglich ist die verboten ist es bis auf
die straßen statt das dann auch mal ein
polizeibeamter vorbeikommt und klingelt
und fragt was da los ist
das ist unglaublich ein großer
unterschied dazu ob man jetzt mit
taschenlampen durch fenster des nachts
so was sich den uns hier so halte ich
für falsch das muss man auch nicht
machen aber eine klare ansage dass es
verboten ist das ist glaube ich
notwendig an der stelle frau bringt man
zwei fragen noch einmal das zitat der
kanzlerin bei 75 prozent der infizierten
wissen wir nicht wo sie sich angesteckt
hat das heißt geschäftsreisen können
eigentlich genauso gefährlich sein
wie urlaub und arbeiten kann eigentlich
genauso gefährlich sein wie feiern und
wir wissen ist einfach nur nicht also ja
die kontakte sind schlecht der aber bei
der feier kommen viele menschen auf
engem raum zusammen ja auch für längere
zeit und sie tragen in der regel auch
keine maske ja und die geschäftsreise da
sind ja weniger kontakte vorhanden ja
klar ich muss von a nach b und aus
infektiologe sich gesprochen
klettern wir alle für vier wochen auf
einen baum
ja und dann ist spuk vorbei ja das
funktioniert aber nicht also müssen wir
irgendwelche alternativen finden
das ist eine pandemie das ist wie sie
schon sagten geraten gesundheitsnotstand
und wir können nicht alle für vier
wochen auf dem baum klettern das leben
muss irgendwie weitergehen ja es gibt
nur blöde wege aus dieser pandemie
gerade raus und wir müssen gerade den
weg finden der am wenigsten weh tut und
das wird wirklich versucht ja und das
ist vielleicht nicht ideal aber wir
müssen ja irgendwo anfangen und dann
nochmal oder entschuldigungen machen sie
weiter ich wollte ihr solltet jetzt
wirklich gern noch einmal mit herrn
gassen diskutieren was vor teichert
gerade so schön angesprochen hat ihre
idee wie wir jetzt die strategie ändern
bei der kontakt verfolgung und wer hat
noch einen anderen punkt hier gerade in
dem ein spieler wie sie sich diese ampel
vorstellen das würde ich wirklich jetzt
gerne mal erklärt der kirche noch ja
super zunächst war frau kollegin teich
hat sehen sie es mir bitte nach
natürlich sind sie kolleginnen aber ich
muss gestehen offensichtlich noch nicht
im hybrid format richtig angekommen
also bitte um verzeihung jetzt möchte
ich aber gerne auf die punkte von frau
bringt man eingehen also zum einen wir
haben es wurde kurz eingeblendet
verschiedene aspekte und natürlich ist
die kontakt verfolgen mich völlig bei
vorteil hat wichtig aber wir wissen auch
und ich habe schreiben aus verschiedenen
gesundheitsämtern dass das eben seit
einiger zeit nicht möglich ist aufgrund
der schieren menge das ist auch völlig
klar
deshalb hat mir gesagt man sollte wenn
das im moment nicht leistbar ist sich
auf die fokussieren wo es wirklich
unabdingbar ist und das sind nur die
risiko die wohlhabend und gruppen von
denen wir wissen dass sie schwer
erkrankt und am inn auf
intensivstationen land möge und wenn es
dann wieder bei allen geht umso besser
aber das ist im moment nicht absehbar
insofern und das ist das was auch die
leopoldina empfiehlt dass wir uns dann
auf die konzentrieren
das andere ist das ampelsystem und das
ampel system ist deshalb aus unserer
sicht wichtig und gerade für die region
wichtig weil eben unterschiedliche
infekt geschehen war siemens von
geschildert saarland bayern mecklenburg
vorpommern hat immer noch relativ
entspannte situation dass wir hier eine
möglichkeit schaffen dass regional auch
massnahmen ergriffen können die sie in
anderen regionen nicht brauchen und dazu
gehört eben mehr als die
infektionszahlen dazu gehört auch mehr
als der wert der seit einer woche
kontinuierlich sinkt also man könnte
sagen es alles prima der sinkt natürlich
war die zahlen so irre hoch sind und
selbst kleinste aussteller unten den
singles also es ist sehr trügerisch
diese diese was wären denn ihre zahlen
also markus söder sagt die infizierten
zahl ist die mutter aller zahlen ja und
sie sagen sie haben andere welche sind
ihre wir haben nicht andere wir haben
die zahlen die alle haben aber muss
jetzt auch zusammenführen und will das
jetzt nicht kommentieren was herr söder
sagt aber die infektions tag ist ein
punkt ist natürlich deshalb schon
wichtig weil sie einen ungefähren
eindruck über das infekt geschrieben ist
und wir wissen natürlich ein gewisser
prozentsatz von denen wird halt auch
irgendwann schwerer krank deshalb ist
die nicht banal und auch nicht zu
vernachlässigen aber sie ist natürlich
nur teil der wahrheit
das zweite was ganz wichtig ist wie sind
die altersmäßig verteilt und wir haben
gesehen in den letzten wochen dieser
schnitt verschiebt sich es waren
praktisch nur junge am anfang da
passiert nichts wert
einen trick gesagt wenn sich 200 raver
infizieren und waren danach zu hause
wird nicht viel passieren
haben sie 30 infektionen im altenheim
ist das hoch gefährlich das heißt also
auch das alter ist ein relevanter punkt
und dann kommt es natürlich darauf an
wie sind kapazitäten vor ort
und da sind nicht nur intensiv
kapazitäten denn wenn man darauf schaut
das ist sicherlich das ende der gedanke
ist es schon ein brennt die hütte schon
sondern auch wir sind stationäre
kapazitäten und ich würde auch sagen wir
sind die ambulanten kapazitäten vor ort
und diese ganzen dinge muss man in ein
solches ampelsystem einpreisen und wir
wollen eigentlich nie das hier gut wird
und dann muss man lokal maßnahmen
ergreifen und dann kann es durchaus sein
dass man auch vielleicht regional sagt
wir müssen jetzt hier tatsächlich zügel
anziehen
aber das ist dann adjustiert es ist
angepasst ich glaube das ist dann auch
sehr viel effektiver ist und unabhängig
davon und das soll ja gewann hindurch
laufen ist dass die menschen sich an
abstand unigene halten das ist ist ja
ein selbstläufer da muss man halt immer
wieder mahnen die maske da wo sie
sinnvoll ist eine app macht sicherlich
sinn jetzt kann man darüber streiten ob
die man ob ihr hätte besser sein können
aber die die wir haben ist ja nun mal
die die wir haben und das ist gar nicht
so schlecht und adäquates lüften und
dann haben wir schon viel gewonnen und
wenn sich daran alle halten würden
glaube ich hätte mir das schon ich das
stück vielleicht sekunde ich wollte ganz
schnell vorteil hat noch mal fragen im
vorteil hat im grunde ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen ja auch früher schon vor
dem lockdown zurückgegangen die menschen
das wussten wir dann erst drei monate
später
die menschen haben sich also schon vor
den harten maßnahmen adäquat verhalten
warum brauchen wir jetzt wieder in den
hammer wenn es eigentlich damals
funktioniert hat also mit dem wort
hammer bin ich nicht glücklich ich würde
eher anknüpfend an das was frau
brinkmann folgen ja schon gesagt habe
von allen schlechten maßnahmen die alle
wehtun
ist es vielleicht diejenige die am
ehesten noch zu tolerieren ist sie jetzt
getroffen worden ist deswegen finde ich
auch hammer das ist sowas ultimatives
dass das passt in dem kontext nicht so
ganz sondern es ist eine abwägung von
verschiedenen geschichten und es geht
tatsächlich darum die kontakte zu
reduzieren und ich habe da eben schon
mal erklärt für die gesundheitsamt da
ist es wichtig nicht nur dort auch
gassen hat ja gerade sein ampel system
vorgestellt auch dafür benötigt er daten
diese daten bekommt er nur von den
gesundheitsämtern weil die die daten
erfassen und deswegen brauchen wir das
und wir müssen gucken dass wir da wieder
hinkommen dass das funktioniert dass die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung klappt
und dass wir vor allen dingen auch
genügend manpower haben um das
aufzubauen so nun ansonsten rät uns da
einfach die kontrolle das ist das
problem ist wieder die große da ist er
völlig einverstanden sagt herr gassen
der fehlt tatsächlich wieder das
personal und das ist etwas worauf sie
seit märz aufmerksam machen und immer
noch nicht ist viel geschehen frau
teichert wie viel schaffen sie denn
momentan oder sind die gesundheitsämter
vielerorts schon im kollaps also das ist
der grund warum ich auch nicht so
glücklich bin mit den regionalen
maßnahmen weil ich glaube dass wir den
zeitpunkt längst überschritten haben wir
haben ja jetzt nicht mehr um einzelne
hotspots in einzelnen regionen so wie
wir es noch vor ein paar wochen hatten
sondern wir beobachten jetzt quasi
täglich wie sich die karte der
landkreise die die marke von 50
überschreiten rot einfärbt er mir schon
etliche landkreise auch über 100 und 200
und da sieht man dass es jetzt ein
flächenbrand ist wir hatten vorher
einzelne brandherde an verschiedenen
stellen sind jetzt sozusagen
zusammengeflossen es ist ein
flächendeckendes problem was wir in
deutschland haben
und deswegen glaube ich sind regionale
maßnahmen in dem sinne jetzt überholt
das hätte man vor wochen und monaten
machen können aber jetzt ist es einfach
einen anderen zeitpunkt jetzt haben wir
einen flächenbrand und den kriegen wir
nur unter kontrolle
wenn alle mitmachen sich an die regeln
halten so wie es ja auch eben schon
gesagt wurde
und wenn wir die kontakte reduzieren und
genau das soll ja jetzt passiert so
fordern sie einen punkt er selbst mit
der gassen ampel wenn man die jetzt mal
auf deutschland interpoliert und sich
das anschaut werden wir doch auch fast
überall auf rot weil doch einfach die
belegung auf den krankenhaus stationen
ansteigt selbst intensivbetten sind ja
nicht unendlich und so ihrer aufzählung
kommt ja noch dazu dass sich
pflegekräfte brauchen um diese betten
überhaupt bedienen zu können
und da kommen wir im moment eine sehr
bedrohliche situation wenn wir nicht
gegensteuern
deshalb wir können diese ampel gerne
machen
wenn wir aus diesem mini lockdown oder
wellenbrecher lockdown rausgekommen sind
da habe ich überhaupt nichts dagegen für
transparenz und solche maßnahmen und
auch zahlen zu veröffentlichen
aber fakt ist doch dass das was vorteil
hat sagt stimmt wir sind jetzt im moment
kurz vor rot flächendeckend egal nach
welcher ampelregelungen deswegen müssen
wir jetzt handeln noch mal verbringt man
die frage das ja auch das schon menschen
voraus gedacht haben ein nicht ganz
unbekannter biologen kollege christian
drosten hat im august also vor drei
monaten vorgeschlagen sich auf die so
genannten quelle cluster zu
konzentrieren also auf die cluster die
ursächlich sind für eine infektion warum
liegen so eine idee so lange und warum
sind wir jetzt schon wieder so
überrascht von allem
ja also das ist eine gute idee das
funktioniert aber auch nicht mehr wenn
es einem so aus dem ruder läuft gerade
passiert ja dann muss ich wieder
komplett die kontrolle auch schon wieder
erlangen und ich finde es keiner
widerspricht erlassen wenn sie sagen wir
müssen auf die aha regeln + l + corona
pachten
das ist das ist nichts neues was sie da
in ihrem papier schreiben das ist ja
gegeben ja und auch dass wir die älteren
besonders schützen sind ja ja das passt
aber das passiert ja also ihr
ampelsystem wollte ich auch noch mal
kurz zu sagen
kein seriöser wissenschaftler oder
politiker hat nur auf die zahl der
neuinfektionen geschaut die sind aber
der früheste indikator den wir haben und
selbst die sind nicht tagesaktuell also
auf den tag sagen wenig wie für sich
heute angesteckt haben auch das ist
sieben tage in die vergangenheit ja ich
gucke immer sieben tage zurück und noch
weiter zurück schaue ich bei den anderen
zahlen die jetzt alle sich genau so
entwickeln wie es eigentlich die zahl
der neuinfektionen gemacht haben die
zahlen vom lka waren vorhanden für jeden
einsehbar wie es in die älteren
bevölkerungsgruppen jetzt auch
eingetragen wird der an vergleich zum
sommer hat man diesen trend ganz klar
gesehen konnte jeder nachgucken hat auch
jeder keiner guckt nur auf eine zahl wir
gucken auf den erwehrte gucken auf die
anzahl der test sie durchgeführt werden
auf die positiv rate der test
oder alte werte sind gestiegen und
versioniert in ihrem papier fehlt ist
die idee wie wir das exponentielle
wachstum was wir gerade haben diese
dynamik wie unterbrechen werde jetzt das
schaffen wir nicht mehr durch die aa
plus r regeln das braucht es wieder die
kontrolle durch die berühmtheit ämter da
müssen wir erst mal runter erzählen sie
mir doch mal wie sie jetzt mit diesem
exponentiellen wachstum bei meinem auge
bei ihrer aufzählung fehlte die dynamik
ja ich war ja die erste frage die sie
eigentlich die kurve wieder flattrigen
wollt also wie wir die kurve wieder
flach klingen ja also ist doch
offensichtlich dass für eine
differenzierte nachverfolgung die viren
und die infektionszahlen runter gehen
muss ab einer gewissen grenze
funktionieren all die maßnahmen die wir
geglaubt haben dass sie funktionieren
nicht mehr so weswegen ich glaube jeder
wünscht sich ein differenziertes
vorgehen das regional abgestuft ist
schön nachverfolgen und da wo das virus
ausbricht ging er sofort hin und
kontaminieren ist und schwer sein und
dann können wir alle weiterarbeiten aber
es funktioniert halt nicht deswegen
glaube ich muss es jetzt so sein wie es
beschlossen wurde und umgesetzt werde
die entscheidende frage ist doch wie
verhindern wir dass ist in drei vier
wochen nach weihnachten die der kommt ja
das ist doch die entscheidende frage wir
haben jetzt vier wochen das was wir in
den vier monaten davor nicht geschafft
haben besser zu machen
deshalb suche ich denken und da finde
ich kann man jetzt nicht sagen alles ist
gut gewesen davor wir hatten ja so ein
bisschen da am anfang uns die bälle
zugeschoben
und in der tat muss man sagen für die
risikogruppen den ich in heimen sind
gibt es keine antwort gibt es keine
besonderen schutz massen haben ist ja
ganz einfach zu sagen risikogruppen
kriegen fb2 massen auf krankenschein
oder kriegen die umsonst auf rezept oder
wie auch immer werden einfach ausgeteilt
es wäre natürlich möglich die app so zu
nutzen dass die gesundheitsämter wenn
ich mich infizieren würde da ist
automatisch mitbekommen
es wäre natürlich möglich flächendeckend
luft reinigungsanlagen auszurollen
es wäre natürlich möglich jetzt schon
vorsorge zu treffen dass klassen kleiner
sind falls es dann zur ausbreitung kommt
also wir haben ja noch überhaupt nicht
alles umgesetzt und ich glaube wenn wir
die diskussionen fruchtbar führen wollen
dann nehmen wir jetzt die entscheidung
so wie sie gestern gab
die gerichte werden darüber urteilen das
stimmt hoffentlich wird es gut
juristisch begründet werden
da kann man zweifel haben wir haben wir
schon beim anderen maßnahmen und gesagt
das hat die politik falsch gemacht aber
vor allem ist doch anscheinend jetzt
diese vier wochen zu nutzen um deshalb
zu sein als zu den letzten vier monaten
klar aber noch war die nachfrage und
darüber müssen sie sich auch gedanken
gemacht haben
sonst würde ich mich sehr täuschen wenn
es allein um die härte der maßnahmen
geht allein um die härte der reaktion
des staates auf dieses
infektionsgeschehen dann müssten andere
länder viel besser da stehen als jetzt
hast du bestimmt ja und das sind ja auch
ich meine das ist ja das ist muss man
wahrscheinlich zu geben das müssen sie
ja beantworten ich endlich gehören aber
wissen für die winter und die leute
gehen rein in italien sind 22 grad die
leute können immer noch draussen sein
also das infektionsgeschehen irgendwo
auf eine ursache zurück zur zeit
irgendwie nicht so richtig zu
funktionieren klar gibt indikatoren
ländliche räume wo die bevölkerung
bisschen weiter auseinander lebt
scheinen ich komme ja aus
schleswig-holstein scheint später dran
zu sein aber es frisst sich eben auch
wenn die ländlichen räume rein klar die
schwäbische alb ist nicht stuttgart und
trotzdem steigen da jetzt die zahlen und
jetzt ist auch rot also nur zu sagen es
gibt in ein faktor unter schützt uns das
wetter die die dichte der bevölkerung
das haushalt auch nicht hin also am ende
glaube ich haben wir das virus immer
noch nicht wirklich verstanden also in
letzter konsequenz wir sind ein bisschen
vielleicht mehr als im märz aber alles
wissen wir nicht sonst wäre es
unerklärlich findet wir sind ja doch
irgendwie alle überrascht über die
massivität des ausbruchs so und trotzdem
kann man jetzt analysieren was davor
nicht ausreichend gut getan wurde
natürlich das weiß ich doch herr hans
und seine kollegen die
gesundheitsministerin und minister alle
arbeiten sich die hacken wund also
niemand leider stellt wurstigkeit und
lässigkeit oder so etwas
aber man muss glaube ich jetzt schon
schauen wo hätte man besser sein können
und geld scheint ja als vorsorgeprinzip
keine rolle zu spielen dann sollten wir
auch massiv reingegangen